we're active we're doing literally
nothing in my active way I'm smoking a
cigarette and my active we're at the
grocery store at that grocery I believe
that each and every one of us has the
power within ourselves to create the
life that we really want and I want to
help give you the tools to make that
happen
I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today's show is with the very strong
confident and determined and wonderful
Melissa Hartwig urban I found out about
Melissa way back when I started CrossFit
paleo is a diet who very oriented to the
CrossFit world and so then of course
then there's little this little subset
within paleo called whole 30 and I don't
think that she meant to do it like that
but it's got a lot of foundational
similarities to paleo with certain foods
that you are encouraged to eat more and
ones that you aren't but she talked
about of course the birth of whole 30
and what that looked like
and the struggles that she's had as a
person and the places that she's grown
we talked about her love for hiking she
calls it her church and we just you know
I learned a lot about food and I learned
a lot about you know why we do what we
do why we eat the way we do and and and
it's a fantastic platform to really have
a better relationship with food doing
the whole 30 program which is something
I'm passionate about I really believe
that we need to develop a positive
relationship with food and stop looking
at healthy food as a punishment and cake
as a reward that's that's there's
something fundamentally wrong with that
so we had a great conversation she also
has a new book coming out hole 30
friends and family so please pick that
up as I'm sure it has plenty of amazing
recipes for of course your friends and
family enjoy I did whole 21 yeah you are
so good you finished it early I say like
I'm pretty well practiced in like eating
paleo and not eating
you know many sugars at all I do they're
the natural like honey or maple syrup
it's really it's like honey I'd say it's
common and if I make a cookie it'd be
coconut sugar but I don't really make
them because I don't want to eat them
yeah so it's really uncommon for me to
really need too much anyway it comes in
more of the form of like chocolate chips
have added stuff or something like that
but so I did hold I was gonna do whole I
didn't even know if I actually was
planning to do whole 30 I just planned
to do whole 30 eating for the this
period of time until I left for vacation
oh yeah and I ended up drinking the
first night I arrived which made it I
think maybe the whole 21 instead of two
or something but anyway yeah it was it I
just I I love it
I think that it is such a wake-up call
for people to pay attention to what
they're eating pay attention to labels
like we were just talking about to
understand what's in their food and of
course at the end of the day it's really
about developing a healthy relationship
with food right it's it's about food as
medicine instead of looking at it as a
punishment or reward so I mean
personally thank you and I mean like
it's you've changed people's lives and
I'm sure you know that but it you have
I'm glad thank you so I want to hear
your version of the Thin Mint story of
how the whole thirty came along so I
mean it really started like back when I
was in college and I developed a drug
addiction and so I spent about five
years in school dropped out of school as
an addict and when I went into rehab
almost 20 years ago now I realized that
I had to change everything about my life
if I was gonna stay in recovery
so I started exercising I started going
to the gym I made a new group of
girlfriends who are into running and
other like healthy pursuits who actually
like talked about their feelings I
changed my clothes I changed my job like
I changed everything and I really began
to pursue health and fitness through
that Avenue and I was very focused on my
athletic performance I was very into
CrossFit a little bit later on and so
you know thinking about athletic
performance and recovery I remember
sitting around after a really difficult
Olympic lifting session and my original
is in there
clean injure know is like a limp we were
at CrossFit Boston yeah I didn't Kowski
was teaching us how to snatch no I
learned that suck at snatch I'm not I
mean I'm like 510 and a half we would
not get all our rulers are like that but
it was a really good session it was a
really hard session so we were sitting
around after eating and I you know my
original co-founder said to me I wonder
what would happen if we did this like
squeaky clean kind of according to like
a paleo style diet anti-inflammatory
approach for 30 days I cleaned up just
the last 20% cuz paleo is so rooted in
CrossFit like it very much the adopted
diet of cross it was and this was back
in 2009 so it really was yep um and I
like to Whole Foods approach I was
already doing mostly a Whole Foods
approach but at the time that he's
suggesting this I'm eating Thin Mints
right out of the sleeve because I had
just exercised and I had earned them and
I was like yeah that sounds really good
like let's do it when do you want to
start and he said right no why don't we
start right now and I'm very like black
or white on or off but things that made
me a good addict to make me really good
at these kind of challenges so I was
like cool I handed my Thin Mints over
and that was really the start of the
first whole thirty back in April 2009 I
was like a personal self experiment how
did you create the guidelines so we
based it on the framework of a paleo
diet which you know was like meat
seafood and eggs lots of vegetables and
fruit natural healthy fats but I knew
for me that there were some other kind
of a nice thing pointed out the things
you do get to eat instead of don't I'm
usually like no grains no dairy no beans
no red no no no no no
no no there's no my first rodeo I should
have approached good job good job cuz
there's a lot of stuff you can eat so
those words totally we were focusing on
but I also knew that if I was allowed to
like recreate some of my comfort food or
technically compliant ingredients that
was B that would be problematic I was
also kind of obsessed with like the
scale in the mirror I didn't have weight
to lose but I was really obsessed with
like my body comp and was I getting more
muscular and was I getting leaner like
goal-oriented yeah food yeah but not in
a super healthy way like I had a
relatively dysfunctional as many of us
did growing up like relationship with
food in my body I think being a girl is
even harder to it's very hard it's
really hard and then I also had some
weird like body image issues based on
the fact that I was an addict and I was
like super skinny and not at all healthy
and like you know weak as a noodle so I
had a lot of stuff to prove I feel like
so this 30-day experiment helped
identify for me all the ways that I was
using food like I used to use drugs as
punishment as a reward to relieve
anxiety to self-soothe to comfort myself
but it also in like removing the foods
that I I couldn't turn to for those
reasons that helped me develop other
coping mechanisms and I finally felt
like for the first time I was able to
get off the scale and out of the mirror
it was really powerful what were your
other coping magnet talking to actual
human beings about how I felt I still
wasn't very good at it but it was like a
relatively new concept for me so that
whaling good just sitting you know
sitting in my feelings I'm not using the
gym for punishment the first two weeks
of whole xxx are a little bit rough in
that your energy can be down I was very
dependent on sugar and didn't realize it
so I couldn't go into the gym to beat
myself up so I would go for walks or
hikes and that felt like a nice or like
a you were a little little little
depleted yeah yeah
so I I think I just in the absence of
realizing how often I would turn to
these foods you know I'm having a bad
day it's this I feel like crap this I
didn't have a good workout this yeah
it's just the awareness I think was so
important it's also frustrating to me
because I love working out and I love
eating healthy and I can't barely
remember a time that I didn't I mean
I've been working out since I was a kid
like 14 years old I've been eating
healthy since I was probably or at least
trying yeah the version of healthy has
ever ever evolved that weaker I'm sure
the
you'll improve on hole 30 someday and to
some more and like you know it'll have
adaptogens in it in the future whatever
like I'm part of the regiment but look
it's always evolving which is the fun
part about health and nutrition and and
wellness overall but I mean I was young
when I was trying to eat healthy and
it's always been something that's been
so much of a passion of mine so it's
hard for me to relate to people that are
like oh I have to go to the gym I'm like
I'll go to the gym and I love two-a-days
yeah you know sure yeah it is I'm like
I'm just consciously thinking I'm
probably pretty depleted yeah by doing
that but and then with food I'm like I
love the challenge of making really
healthy food that tastes amazing yeah
people come over for dinner and I've
dinner and oh they'll love it and I
don't even bother to tell them the
criteria thankfully they kind of know
now by me but like there's no point in
having it so why is that like what is
what what is the psyche what is it a
cultural conditioning like what's the
what's the why do we do that Wow okay so
it's obviously not that like it's just
in some people and not in others because
I did not exercise until I got out of
rehab I never hit a gym I wasn't
particularly into eating healthy and
then I had like the most horrific the
unhealthy period you could imagine in
college so you know I think part of it
is just the adaption of a growth mindset
I think that's so important for Apple to
realize that you know I growing up I
wasn't athletically inclined I didn't
play sports I was like a total bookworm
nerd and then to realize that like I can
if I if I go and apply myself and I'm
dedicated and committed and I work hard
I can like change my strengths and I can
change my agility and my coordination
like that was really important part of
it is just consistency so turning what
you know originally feels like a slaw
like I didn't love going to the gym
every single morning that I went to the
gym when I first got started but I
created some kind of habit hacks that
helped me stay consistent until it felt
good lying laying my gym clothes out
every single night the night before and
I would pick like really cute gym
clothes that I was excited to wear so I
would lay it all out top to bottom
everything down like my
we're in socks and then I would tell
myself in the morning all you have to do
is put your gym clothes on if you still
don't want to go to the gym you don't
have to but you do have to put your gym
clothes on and then when you're in gym
clothes you feel stupid just sitting
around the house so I don't variably go
you've seen that leisure video like yeah
I'm doing absolutely not active we're
very active we're doing literally
nothing in my active we're smoking a
cigarette and my active we're at the
grocery store at that grocery this was
before the athleisure trend where like
you only wore gym clothes to go to the
gym then it was like early in the days
of Lululemon so you know champion short
I said my stuff any old t-shirt exactly
but those are some things I did until I
got really consistent and then I think
the other piece of it is just if you can
get the ball rolling in one area and I
really think food is such a good
foundation yeah feeling in control of
your food in a way not in like a overly
restrictive way but in a way that makes
you feel like you're really nourishing
yourself and taking good care of
yourself gives you capacity to want to
take tackle other areas of your life
whether it's exercise or stress or sleep
or meditation like you're like I feel
good and then it gets you on this good
happy and nourish ah routine where
you're like now what else can I also
feel like the way that you treat
yourself is how you treat other people
oh yeah so I don't I don't know how you
were as a person before hole 30 or even
exactly right now but I'm a man I would
imagine that the person that you were
before you started taking care of
yourself appropriately
it was probably reflected in your
relationships oh my gosh yeah and I
firmly believe that because you see
people that are you know they don't look
healthy and they're also not freaking
nice yeah they're edgy they're they're
moody they're rude they're offended
they're judgmental yeah and it's like
you can't treat someone a ttle at a
higher level until you reach it yeah I
mean I in my very first whole thirty I
worked in an office 9:00 to 5:00 and I
managed a group of like 20 young women
all women and about halfway through I
would be doing my morning meeting and
someone said to me like what have you
been doing cuz you're really nice and
like I would walk into the meeting and
I'm like I don't want to hear about your
weekend we have a lot of stuff to do and
I've got a half an hour to get it done
and I was more social I was more
outgoing I was wearing
I was more compassionate because I was
being that way with myself and it wasn't
until and you're absolutely right it's
not until you unlock that in yourself
that you can see that translating into
how you show up in the rest of the world
and that also feels good it's like when
someone says to you oh you look
beautiful
yeah you don't think you look beautiful
right right what do you do you go
whatever
yeah you can't it can't register in you
until you feel it it's true and also the
thing I remember is that like me saying
you look beautiful has nothing to do
with you and everything about how I'm
choosing to experience you so if you
cannot see that about yourself then it's
a lot easier to accept that compliment
and say like well I'm really glad that
that's how you're seeing yourself and
maybe then begin to take some of that on
yourself yeah yeah yeah that's beautiful
so how did like so you do the experiment
what did how did it go by the way like
what other than other than being kind of
tired at the beginning oh no it was
awesome okay I woke up a Sunday like 14
and felt like someone had flipped a
switch in terms of my energy what were
you eating before that I was meeting
reading Thin Mints you were eating
gluten oh yeah yeah I was eating like
Whole Foods but it was kind of a
bodybuilder like Zone diet style he's
just hitting macros and not worrying
about no I was never counting or
tracking but it was like you know lots
of cottage cheese lots of low-fat dairy
lots of whole grains like kind of what
everyone thought was healthy of course
again like I tried to be healthy and I
ate cottage cheese for dinner yeah I
think you're eating healthy so doing
fine on what so you cut out you
basically had to cut out all the
categories right you had to cut out
gluten you had to cut out dairy
yeah and cut out I was already eating a
lot of vegetables so I just ate more
vegetables I was you know I'm trying to
think of like I had to cut out by like
Dunkin Donuts caramel macchiatos and
reliving oh yeah I know I still love
those my breakfast every morning used to
be like a whole grain bagel and like one
of those caramel drinks from one guys my
girlfriend and I when we were kids we
would ride our roller blades from her
house to to the bagel shop yeah we
wouldn't have one we would have two yeah
and I thought oh well it's no fat in the
bagel I'm eating a like cream cheese I
know yes I know oh my god and then we
had driving hood I know she was also the
friend that I was like you know low fat
we would dip white bread into fat-free
Italian dress
and just go for it yeah we would make
dinner and we'd have chicken because it
was low-fat and then there's a picture I
wish I still had it or wish I knew where
it was but it was bowls of fruit and it
was like pineapple Kiwi strawberry and
it was probably a dozen yeah and that
was our dinner and I was like oh we did
the best we could but I changed it up
and like my energy became really
consistent so yeah no more 2 p.m.
head-on dusk kind of slump I started
waking up really effortlessly without an
alarm my sleep got so much better which
I think sleep is such an underrated
benefit of the whole 30 I'm like I said
my mood improved so people could kind of
tell that I was happier um my
performance in the gym eventually did
improve after the first week or two and
it wasn't that my performance was better
I just felt like I was recovering faster
which of course leads to better
performance yeah so all of these were
really important but the most important
thing was that I feel like it profoundly
shifted my emotional relationship with
food like just in that 30-day period go
mad about that you know I never really
thought about my relationship with food
if you'd asked me what it was I would
have been like I don't know I eat it
because I need it because I exercise but
in thinking about you know the way I
turned to food for things like comfort
or to self-soothe thinking about how
automatic it was that I didn't really
have other coping strategies other than
to like eat which is something that I
think so many people can relate to
because it's so accessible it's so
rewarding it's so societally encouraged
it's more opinionated hammered on beer
you know whatever I would I have a fight
with the boyfriend and have a pint of
you know whatever yeah so I think it
just opened up this like level of
awareness and it shifted something in
terms of my relationship with food like
permanently in a way that allowed me to
have like a new foundation to move
forward and I'm going to build I think
that's what's important about an
extended period and actually while I am
like you know because there's a lot of
people I know that have done it
especially since I've been doing
Crossfit since 2013 or staff people that
do have done whole thirty again I've
done a whole twenty-one but you know the
that that rigidity on though cheating
and starting over yeah look I don't yet
it's I can do it I think it's tough but
here's that here's the thing that's the
best about most people
because I have friends that are like oh
I've been eating mostly I'm like well
are you eating something like that every
day or eating like are you having gluten
or you have it right every day they're
like yeah but I'm like we'll never know
then yeah it's not like you have it once
every 10 days or once every month it's
not like it's not like you have it you
have it every day your body will never
know what it's like to remove those
inflammatory items until you actually do
yeah it's okay level of cheating varies
dramatically yeah so when you remove all
cheating period you really force people
to be accountable yeah and do it right
yes and it's actually easier for the
brain to process black and white
instructions it's easier for me to say
to you know added sugar if there's any
sugar in the ingredient list out yeah
then for me to say to you eat less sugar
and then you're going to the grocery
store you're reading the label and
you're like well it's got two grams as
two grams less less than what what if I
add it with the other four grams your
red card like there's a lot of effort
and you're expending a lot of willpower
and that whereas if I just say like here
are the very black-and-white rules to
this animation program you're like okay
great because most of the time like for
this period of thirty days people find
that like it's so freeing to be told
exactly what to eat and then it just
gives you a good foundation for what you
do after because you're not meant to eat
like this forever when you figure out
what you're you know ongoing plan looks
like right well it gets pretty hard to
like go out to dinner so you can't you
know I mean it gets challenging
yeah I've been dressing so yeah I
remember having a dressing one time I
was like wow it's like a balsamic or
something or like some kind of herb
vinaigrette or whatever whatever you can
kind of find that you get on the side
that you dip your fork in yeah and I'm
like god that's good and I was like
what's in that yeah powdered sugar oh
yeah of course I know they put sugar and
everything powdered sugar and I'm like
well that shit's delicious I know how I
know why so what was the worst part
like what did or what you know what I'm
more interested in I'm more interested
in like what was the hardest transition
for you to like navigate as you went
through this 30 days of deep diving into
having to cope in new ways yeah I mean I
didn't find a ton of it too hard I'm a
Gretchen Rubin upholder like when I
decided to do something I just do it
it's not hard for me I also have no
problem like I'm not a people pleaser so
I don't have a hard time holding
boundaries so it was like going out with
she wanted to drink and I was like no
I'm not drinking like that's not hard
for me at all so I didn't have any of
those struggles I think you know maybe
turning it into like a sustainable
lifestyle I think is the hardest part
for everybody
how'd you come out of it I came out of
it with reintroduction which you're
supposed to do very carefully and
systematically I learned a lot I know
that's in the book was for me didn't
even read the program yet so is the
douche breath program based on like what
you did and then very no and the very
first how'd you come up with it you go
to McDonald's did you like I have a
cookie did you like get a glass of wine
I don't know I would drink wine I'm 100%
certain I definitely came out of it
really slowly because I felt so good
like I didn't want it to go okay I mean
it was like this whole new level of like
Energizer Bunny I agree when I cut out
gluten and dairy back in 2000 yeah that
was 13 I didn't go paleo until 2016 but
in 13 I went gluten and dairy and that
was the one that was the biggest
transition for me I yeah and then I
would say that I told I mean the the my
energy was the biggest thing yeah just
sustained yeah always good energy uh-huh
to the point where it rarely I have a
bad energy day and if I do I'm like
what's wrong yes what's wrong but did I
eat something wrong is it allergies
what's happening yeah am I gonna yeah
yeah great great it's wonderful so I
don't you know I don't really remember
like I don't I feel like I did my second
whole 30 it might have been six months
later or so like not too too much later
I really ate gosh it was almost 10 years
ago I was like what's it really yeah it
was not it was 2009 yeah the time yeah
anniversary um so I definitely came off
it slowly that much I remember and I
definitely remember thinking like what
was worth it although this framework for
food freedom wasn't not yet invented
what was worth it for me was like the
program sounded like arson smaller so
instead of going off of it and you
having this memory of like man I went to
know very ween that plowed through oh
okay in fact I remember I remember
eating a bite of my beloved in
enlightened fat yogurts and thinking
this tastes like chemicals and how did I
never notice this before yeah so I had
this newfound awareness of like what I
used to eat and like things that used to
feel like a treat no longer felt like a
treat because they made me feel like
sugars fake sugars especially so bad I
know I'm gonna have sure I'd rather be
like okay let's put some maple syrup on
yeah like where but I'm not like I I
can't like for me fake sugars have such
a weird taste oh yeah I can't I couldn't
do it anymore um so there there were
definitely things where I was like I
can't believe it okay how long did it
take to go from the first the first
whole 30 organic whole 30 that was done
to starting to write the program while
in April 2009 was the self experiment by
July 2009 a rudimentary set of rules
were was on my training blog my CrossFit
training blog because I had this awesome
shirt yeah and I had this audience that
was following me for my CrossFit stuff I
owned a CrossFit gym at the time and I
was traveling teaching code about shirts
with Jeff Marton and stuff I was pretty
well invested you were totally in a
crowd I wasn't like you were like doing
it you were in it yeah I was I was um
and so I wrote I was like I did this
thing it was pretty cool I had good
results like would anyone want to do it
with me and a couple hundred people on
my blog we're like yeah I would do it so
I wrote up it's like still out there
this very basic set of rules and in July
2009 so 10 years ago I led what was to
be the first group whole 30 in the
comments on my blog spot yeah really
cool then you start writing the book the
book I started writing in 2011 yeah did
anything change well the book was so
heavily researched that was kind of what
my original co-founder that was his job
he was really into like the science and
the research and making sure that there
is validity for everything yeah what the
layers were - yeah I know actually
putting pen to paper and like inking
uh-huh medicine a lot of research we
wanted to make sure that all of the
recommendations were first grounded in
science and then also grounded in like
clinical experience watching hundreds of
people at this point use runnings of
your own experiments or it's not like
orgies yeah researching them researching
making sure that sort of the idea that
like these foods could be potentially
problematic for digestion or
inflammation existed in the literature
and then having observed at this point
now over the last three years by the
time I'm writing the book or two years
thousands of people going through the
program reporting remarkably similar
results you know if one person or two
people get good results you're like
that's interesting if like a hundred
people report similar results you're
like okay we're onto something
so there was a lot of reading there's a
lot of research there was a lot of like
making sure that we laid it out in a way
that made sense to people and kind of
told a story and then yeah we just put
pen to paper and wanted to get it out
there so that we were instead of talking
to 100 people at a CrossFit gym right we
were hopefully talking to thousands of
people through I feel like that's when I
found out it was with the book I feel
like the book was like them because I
don't I didn't see it on a blog I mean I
just yeah yeah
but I feel like from the origin of like
being in CrossFit I feel like I knew
about yeah 30 we were traveling to
CrossFit gyms three weekends a month for
two years in a row like just going from
Jim - Jim - Jim just through word of
mouth basic job right so we were based
in Utah we went part of it moving from
New Hampshire to Utah like strung a
bunch of road trips together but yeah
just traveling talking to cross I did I
would do a seminar across fat New York
over yeah number you know we were
everywhere we did a seminar at CrossFit
reykjavik like we were in a whole bunch
of different places really well you went
and saw the daughters we did yeah yeah
those who don't know the daughters be
like Annie Thorisdottir yeah David's
daughter that there's Eggman's daughter
far more daughters now beautiful strong
people that's their big into CrossFit
over there yeah I travelled a ton and
then you know put the book out and that
was I think when the program that was
when we started to get our first like
national media attention was with the
book yeah that's I mean what a such a
big deal so the how much did the
researcher like did you have to I feel
like is so big did you have investors or
some saw some kind now we know we've
been self-funded the whole time just you
and me and that the researcher just my
so my researcher was my original
co-founder who's also my ex-husband so
like there's that whole layer of things
okay but we founded the program together
but then when we were doing the research
we also consulted medical doctors and
registered dieticians and PhDs like we
were working with a lot of really smart
people in the field to mirror that we
had the requisite kind of science to
back up our rec ohs yeah yeah I was kind
of curious like I feel like whole 30 or
even paleo just changing your diet don't
even like to call them diets for like
changing your diet there's so many
people that make excuses
and they'll kind of want to do right
they'll want to do it but then like but
you know I have a kid and then I did it
and then they're like but I'm like and
then I got sick and then you know what
do you is this just a symptom of lack of
strike how do you deal with people that
are making excuses because I think this
will probably also happen for a lot of
people let's say there's a man or a
woman or you know someone in a
relationship that wants to do the
program but the other person yeah
doesn't I mean how how have you given
advice on how to oh yeah that we did a
survey it's like 75 percent of whole 30
years are doing it by themselves without
a spouse or partner without a church
group or a gym group like they're doing
it on their own this was a couple years
ago so it may have changed but I was
really surprised as well that's crazy
yeah which is part of why you know we
created like our coaching program to
give people that in-person social
support but most people are just kind of
coming to us through the website the
idea of excuses is interesting one thing
I learned a really long time ago is that
you can't win an emotional argument with
logic so you'll say to me I really want
to do the whole 30 but I don't have time
to meal plan and what that sounds like
to me is can you help me a meal plan so
I'll say oh okay it's fine I'll come
over on Saturday we'll plan a week's
worth of meals I'll help you grocery
shop and invariably you're gonna go okay
and then you're gonna come back with
something else yeah
argue right isn't really that you don't
have time to meal plan there's something
underneath that like very scary about
this approach so anytime I hear the
excuses start to come out the first
question I ask is like what about this
experience is like really scary to you
what worries you like what what's the
kind of worst-case scenario here or like
what emotionally is holding you back
because that's the conversation that can
open the door to like what's really
going on there are a number of reasons
that people who really need to change
their diet won't change their diet
they're afraid of failure they're afraid
of success they identify with their
illness like there are a lot of reasons
and getting to the root of those is
what's gonna help them move forward
right what are your thoughts on you
talked about illness right there what
are your thoughts on the origin of it
like as far as do you manifest it like
do you do you do you do you feel like
your thoughts have some control over
your wellness and you know again people
identify with their illness yeah they do
thoughts become things
so I don't know there's like there's a
big part of me that wonders how much of
our wellness is from the psyche yeah I
mean obviously if you looked at any of
the studies of like the effectiveness of
placebos it's very clear that our brain
is incredibly powerful and can influence
all kinds of like physiological function
I get nervous
anytime somebody tries to oversimplify
it to the point where it's like well if
you just fixed your diet you could cure
cancer or if you just started sleeping
more you could help with this disease or
if you just changed your mindset it
would fix everything
and there are so many moving parts food
is a huge part stress is a huge part
sleep your environment your social
interactions and then your mindset so
you know I don't think anyone's ever
been harmed by going to therapy talking
about their feelings and thinking about
how they could possibly unpack some of
this stuff whether it's like trauma or
childhood stuff or you know social
isolation or whatever it might be
what are your what are your approaches
and like how do you deal with growth
traumas situations yeah there opee do
you oh I've done so much therapy are you
always the therapist language I do I've
done everything from like energy work to
all of it talk therapy to EMDR to neural
linguistic programming like I do I've
done all of it cuz I have I mean in my
backgrounds like ABC after-school
special right I've got like sexual abuse
and addiction recovery and you know yeah
a very public marriage ending in divorce
that when my child was only 1 like
there's a lot I got a lot to unpack so
I'm a really big fan of therapy I'm also
just a really big fan of like talking I
feel like these things that the trauma
the guilt the shame like kind of hide in
the dark so the more you can bring them
out into the light and use your voice I
think it's it can be a very empowering
experience I feel like there's a power
in saying things out loud yeah think
about how many things that you just
won't even talk about yeah I don't want
them to be real yeah and then I feel
like it's like I've experienced it too
like you've gone to therapy and all of a
sudden you like you say things for the
first time I don't know it's great I
gave a lot of emotions yes and sometimes
it might be look I may be it might be
talking to one of your friends that you
really trust and you can be vulnerable
with and you
you know you say something to them and
all of a sudden you're like where is
this coming from
yes going to therapy is like you you go
to look at this like one concrete issue
and then your therapist is like cool now
let's pull everything out of the box
going all the way back to when you were
five and like you really do have to work
at that level at some point you know you
can't just take this like one little
issue it's really helpful I think to go
all the way back and try to explore like
all of the areas in which you may be
manifesting themselves narrow as an
adult and like your relationships your
relationship with yourself how you're
showing up in the world and your health
the relationship with the self is to me
like the core of it yes how do you see
yourself how do you what are your past
traumas have you dealt with them I mean
it the self is to me the the greatest
task everything else will fall into
place when I fix this yeah and I think
that's I don't know I feel like that's
such a much more new approach to
wellness it used to be like I feel like
you know go to church like you know you
know like you know just go do something
positive give back I don't know I feel
like this this this new mindset of
looking at yourself is it's really
important yeah it is you know trauma
setting boundaries REE parenting like
these are all things that I feel like
we're having a moment and made it in
part especially the trauma because of
the me to movement you know where we're
now like talking about sexual harassment
and assault way more than we ever have
as a society and I think it's it's
freeing women to people to use their
voices and to seek the help that they
need and to talk about you know these
issues is like a shared issue and a
societal issue to remember the first
thing that you finally admitted to
yourself out loud that was um
maybe sort of like the the where the
shell cracked open yeah saying the word
rape I used to talk about my I would
only say like I've experienced sexual
abuse or I had like I forget I used I
mean I whitewashed it so much and the
first time out loud I just said like I
was raped I mean I still like get a
little lump in my throat saying it out
loud because I think I don't want it to
be true except it is
and the more I say it the more
uncomfortable with it and like it's just
what happened I think that we go ahead
what our the more you talk yeah right
you know just like are able to cope it's
like you it's happened yeah done you can
troll my emotions it's just there it
just happened yeah it wasn't my fault
yeah yep it shouldn't have happened
right yeah it was it's I'm okay now that
word is just there was so much wrapped
up in it in my own head but yeah that
was definitely a big shell crack in a
good way how old were you 16 mmm yeah
young yeah that's um those are those are
tricky things so I feel like now like
you're in this new phase with the food
freedom forever book that came out just
came out this year yeah that was 2016
okay it's been a couple years then or
1700 okay books but yeah what prompted
that one because that's like that's like
I don't know that feels like the full
circle of like the point it right it it
and we go back to yes we go back to like
the unhealthy relationship with food
going like when I eat bad it's a reward
like I treated myself I had stuff that
made me feel like [ __ ] hello or you know
gosh I have to eat broccoli I'm so
punished I have to go to the yeah I'm
like those unhealthy relationships like
to me actually let me let me start with
asking is the point to all of it to
actually not think about food anymore no
it's not I don't want you to not think
about food I want you to be
conscientious and deliberate about food
and I want you to think about whether
it's worth it and whether you want it
that can happen in a split second I do
not spend any more time than a split
second to look at the cookie you offer
me or the brownie or the glass of wine
right myself is it worth that do I want
it it happens like that but I don't want
you to not think about food that's like
that would be like the teenage likes
like Nirvana smells like teen spirit
version of food freedom or you're like
I'm just gonna anything I want and it
doesn't matter and like yeah you can do
it just because I can that's not what
I'm talking about what I want you to do
in terms of food freedom is feel like
you're in control of your food like you
are making conscientious deliberate
decisions about what's worth it and what
you really want in that moment and
way that serves you whether that looks
like eating no cookies or one cookie or
12 cookies if it's conscientious and
deliberate and you're thinking about it
in a in that fashion then that's real
freedom you're setting your own rules
you get to make your own decision but it
doesn't mean you never have to think
about it I think we always should be
thinking about it how has your has your
relationship changed at all from Thin
Mints whole 32 now yeah I mean yeah I
feel like you know I haven't done a
whole 30 and probably four years or so I
probably will never do another one again
the whole point of the whole 30 is to
get you to this food freedom place where
you're gonna created your own rules and
your living your own sense of balance my
food freedom is always changing in terms
of me thinking about what's worth it and
what isn't so like I haven't been
drinking for the past year and that's
new and it's cool I don't miss it I
really like it if I really wanted a
glass of wine I would have it but I just
like don't so that's always in flux but
if I went over that one do you have a
reason for that one with what they're
not drinking yeah it started in
September of last year My partner brain
and my boyfriend doesn't drink he never
has and he's made me more conscientious
of my alcohol consumption just by sake
of being with him like it would be go
out and have a glass of wine but I
wouldn't have to because like I don't
wanna be tipsy in front of him and so in
Clymer I just wouldn't want him to see
me like that I would have you been
around tipsy people like we think I love
drunk people do you freakin love Joe but
if you've never drank before you just
end up looking like sloppy and and I
don't know messy funny I think we think
we're funny everything yeah it was you
think you judge you if you were drunk no
I don't think he would judge me I think
I would be uncomfortable I think I would
feel like I wasn't showing up as me I
used to use alcohol as a way to like
lubricate social situations and I really
wanted to show up for him as me I didn't
want to use alcohol like that so I would
have a glass of wine you know with
dinner yeah but I wouldn't do more and
then in September of last year so a year
over a year ago at this point I was like
I think I'm gonna just like not drink
for a little while and he was like well
everyone's doing this at number whole 30
why don't you just not drink for
September and I was like yeah I will and
so I did and it's just been rolling
stuck I've had three glasses of wine
since one was not worth it and I didn't
finish it and two were very worth it and
they were great what kind was it just
why eat like a glass
one of them was after like a 14 mile
hike uh-huh in Montana though so you
know 14 mile hike I'm sitting with a
burger and some fries and a glass of
wine like that was worth it yeah so you
know my relationship well I make wine so
I was totally gonna give you a taste on
the way out the door but now I guess
I'll just have to keep it for you and
your friend that's okay I mean I I think
that everyone you should respect
everyone's decisions for what it is that
they want to do but what other things
that you get into in that book because
like I mean food freedom I mean yeah
that's I can understand that concept
quite simply but there has to be I mean
there's a there's a whole book so yeah
are there whole thirty is like so easy
for people to follow because it's so
black or white I'm like here's what you
do for 30 days food freedom is like okay
now here's how you take what you've
learned on the whole thirty and turn it
into a diet that works for you your own
kind of perfect plan and that's a lot
harder people still kind of want to be
told what to do like well okay but in my
food freedom is that okay if I do this
is it okay if I have that if I'm gonna
eat sugar and I food freedom what kind
should I eat and the answer is like
whichever one you want whatever you
decide is worth it so the book really
provides like a framework for helping
you figure out what's worth it and what
you really want how to create this diet
for you in a way that doesn't that isn't
me telling you what to eat because
that's not food freedom so I try to
provide as much guide work as I can we
talked about in the moment success
strategies a lot of times we have to
distance ourselves from the immediate
temptation of that food you know you get
so good cookie or a glass of wine oh
there are a number of strategies you can
do you can take a deep breath like
honestly we can get into this fight or
flight panic reflex when we see a
tempting food especially if we've had
this like lifetime of unhealthy habits
and association with this food so just
sitting and taking a deep breath can
help putting the food in a timeout
saying to yourself like okay if I still
want it in five minutes then I'll eat it
but I'm not gonna make and like
irrational in the moment decision where
sort of my brain is overriding what I
really want and so that's a success
strategy imagining what the outcome is
gonna feel like an hour after you eat it
because eating something that provides
instant gratification but makes you feel
like crap for the next 24 hours I'm not
really a treat yeah
and that's how that's for me the biggest
thing yeah yeah when I eat something
that makes me I mean like sure it can
taste good sugar always tastes good yeah
sugar sugar yeah I say yeah but when I
feel like bloated like I have a food
baby I'm like I just want to go to sleep
and wake up and have it be gone because
I feel it feels so uncomfortable not
worth it not me exactly but yeah there's
that there's that downside and then
there is some long-term kind of things
that you can do you know when you think
about things like what what's most
likely to throw you off your healthy
eating game holidays vacations stressful
events and so I provide strategies for
kind of how to navigate those in a way
that like allows you to make the most of
your vacation like it's not that fun to
be on vacation and feel like crap
because you've eaten and drank a bunch
of stuff that you know isn't serving you
so well how can people learn how to take
care of themselves best like what are
what are what are some of the best ways
to be able to go on vacation and not
fall apart yeah I mean I go on baked
look I was on vacation for the 45 of 90
days at the beginning of the year like I
mean yeah and I stay on the programs
yeah like what how do people do it that
I like I really like giving people small
wins so it's like if you are thinking
about taking a mini trip or even just
take even just practice it like on a
weekend where you have a special event
where you're very conscientiously and
deliberately deliberately asking
yourself like is this a special food is
it gonna mess me up if it is how is it
gonna mess me up is the degree that it's
gonna mess me up gonna make it worth it
in the long run like if you're on
vacation on a beach and you want to just
like feel your best and have good energy
and be able to like take you know take
advantage of the situation you're in
you're not gonna want to eat something
that has you out like a light by 11 a.m.
or has you feeling super bloated or like
not comfortable in your skin so thinking
about that ahead of time and really like
conscientiously having those moments
where you're like okay I know I'm in
Mexico I know it's a margarita but it's
11:00 in the morning and I'm not a good
day drinker yeah I ain't gonna serve me
and saying no and passing out there's
always like if there's a very there's a
look like when I go on vacation I'm like
okay I know how to stay away from all of
the the dairy and the gluten and the
grains and the beans like that's yeah me
that's easy right some people don't some
people literally don't know that
garbanzo is a bean yeah
not even in their realm of consciousness
or awareness right and they go and they
have you know you know a fro like a
mixed drink there's you how many people
think that tonic is water ya know right
I know I think sharpen up if ya give a
[ __ ] about yourself you have to
understand food and for me if you can't
if the way that you're gonna learn how
to operate in the real world or out in
at a restaurant or on vacation is you
don't know how to cook yeah yeah I mean
you don't know how to cook you don't
know how it's made yeah food freedom
always starts with a reset whether it's
a whole 30 reset or a vegan reset if
you're a vegan like there there has to
be that reset because until you get to a
place where you feel like your cravings
are under control your blood sugars that
are regulated your hormones are better
balanced your digestion isn't acting up
as much your immune system is calm like
until you get to that place where you
get that good baseline where you feel so
good you're not gonna have anything to
measure it from right see it's really
hard to dump someone into a vacation
eating whatever they've been eating and
be like okay now try to moderate that
yes advice like just everything in
moderation right they're probably not
going on vacation wondering how they're
going to stay on a program right haven't
been on a program then right starting it
right the point is it's like how can
they go to a restaurant and look at a
menu and go I got this yeah because for
me I'm going okay I'm gonna have a fish
when I have vegetables I'm gonna ask you
know I'm gonna say you know can they if
I'm gonna know what says sauteed versus
roasted yeah versus fried yeah I'm know
I know when a fish says sauteed versus
grilled I know what that means like I
know that they pretty much put some kind
of oil or fat on every protein as before
they hand it out to you right there's
oil or butter or something like that
they're gonna or sauces yeah always
asking for that on the side but you have
to actually cook at home to know that
stuff you can't you can't go out to
breakfast and be like oh I you know I I
didn't know that bacon had this in it or
I just dairy in the eggs yeah I didn't
know there was yeah I didn't know they
mixed it with milk when they make the
scrambled egg sir this is why you do a
whole three you do a whole 30 because
the program structure forces you to ask
those
questions to make it your [ __ ] in the
eggs this morning Oh is there Gary in
the eggs can I get shelled eggs instead
yeah and you're cooking at home in the
program so many people have said the
whole 30 taught me how to cook and
that's a huge benefit of the program so
yes it starts with the whole 30 and then
once you reach that baseline now you
have a new foundation to go on vacation
and say yeah okay like can I finish this
vacation feeling as good as I do and I
started like I'm gonna have a margarita
but I'm gonna have I'm gonna do tequila
club soda and lime agave or can I eat it
with a meal or can I just like sip on it
nice and slow and continue to ask myself
as I'm sipping on my doing yeah or it's
also really important to remember though
that this is a lifelong process it's not
like you do a whole 30 and then you like
get it and you're magically in like food
Freedomland
here yeah ha instantly like yeah is it
worth it yeah it's gonna be worth it
ooh that wasn't worth it and then you
learn from it and you do better and
sometimes we need 10 lessons before we
finally like admit that the chips and
salsa are never worth it or whatever
that looks like for you but it's a
process like this is something that
we're going to be continuing to refine
for the rest of our lives but that also
makes it really fun you know you get to
figure out like how much you get to get
away with and bring all this stuff back
into your diet that you love but still
look and feel exactly as good as you
want to look and feel other things since
you've written all your books that are
new for you that you've added in that
are I think you think exciting and some
kind of rejection on maybe what might be
soon to come or well not in terms of the
whole 30 rules cuz we go back and
revisit the science and like it's still
pretty bomb we haven't made a lot of
changes to the rules
I recently personally added white rice
back into my diet and it was like the
clouds parted in the angel saying like I
needed more carbohydrate cuz I hiked a
ton and I just you know as I was working
with it someone who was kind of helping
me figure out cuz I'm not my best
consultant and he had me doing way more
carbohydrate and I was like cool I can
only eat so many sweet potato and like
butternut squash so I started adding
white rice in and it's heaven I eat it
probably every single day now it just
works really well for my system you know
my hiking is better I'm stronger in the
gym like that's been all good so that's
like one personal thing it's not the
funnest you know it's not like I could
say I added back in like peanut butter
cups or something but when people ask me
they're like
you have a guilty pleasure something oh
my gosh you know what I love trail mix
and yeah NOLA they're like really really
that's so lame and I oh and it's
definitely a paleo version - yeah right
now it's pretty hard to get a whole 30
it's pretty hard to get a whole 30
granola yeah some kind of sugar usually
right but but yeah it's it's um it's
definitely easy to find the Paleo
versions of that and I only eat that way
I mean I really only eat paleo well I
have a I have a pretty I'm pretty famous
for my Cadbury Creme Egg my love of
Cadbury cream eggs once a year my mom
sends them to me she used to put him in
my Easter basket every year and she'll
send me three every year and I just save
them all the same time reduced no no no
I spread them out and like honestly one
year people were like did you eat that
damn egg yeah because it's like I can
September melaka but like i just didn't
want it but but it's the least food like
thing i eat and i absolutely love it it
will always be worth it i did a
nostalgia thing yeah i think so it's my
mom like my mom is still sending me
whatever your mom's aren't you what if
your mom sent you like banana bread like
homemade banana grandma style and if it
were like her thing she has like this
one chocolate chip walnut cake that i
also still eat that hand to god includes
a cup of Crisco like straight-up Crisco
not even my mom not even least guard
like and I like the blue jar they can't
like the plants out lid the tub yeah and
oh yeah yeah but I still eat that I will
eat that cake if she makes it yeah
because that's my mom's cake it's like
what it was that my birthday cake
growing up every single year so there
there is absolutely room for food that
is like so terrible for you but so
delicious that you don't want to give it
up that's my food freedom well it's I
was in that's that Association right
it's like it's not like I'm dying to eat
that it's but it's just like I'm not
even thinking too much about it like I
enjoy this I do it right I know how it
makes me feel exactly and I know the up
and the down side of it right I don't
not thinking about it too much
and that's the problem with people who
are like food is I only want to think
about food as fuel I think it's not just
fuel it's like memory and tradition yeah
and I think food can be loved in a way
that's healthy not in a way that is like
abusive and and I want people that have
those associations yeah
yeah I have food is love for me like
food like I feel like - I have you ever
had a garden no no green thumb person no
gardens are great really even herbs
nothing yeah herbs that like herbs I'd
yeah like cutting my own fresh herbs
yeah yeah where do you get your food of
like a farmers market do you just go to
the regular grocery store a little bit
of everything we had a great farmers
market mmm not like yeah we have a great
one I have a meat CSA I use butcher box
so they're like a meat CSA oh yeah
there's all my like wild-caught beef and
chicken and all that is what time you
mentioned the word vegan and it kind of
brought up one thing that I was asking
it about at the beginning yeah so I'm
like what do you think of the you know
plant-based burgers and my conscience is
like so challenged with animals because
I feel really bad and I'm like if I
don't really ever compromise on anything
with health yeah for anything but look
it's all I mean if I had to actually
slit a cow's throat versus eat a
plant-based burger it probably I'm gonna
eat the plant-based burger so you know I
mean this the industry of meat is so and
I think that's something that maybe
paleo keto I mean I'm just gonna I'm not
gonna say whole thorium is gonna say
paleo because it's the sustainable one
but you know there's such an association
with me yeah so like just so much meat I
remember getting sick of eating meat
even at some point in time like I was
doing this program called Renaissance
period ization RP yeah and it was like
they were telling me how many grams of
protein I needed a day and my macros and
the timing and I'm like I'm so sick of
meat right now I can't eat that much
meat yeah and it's like so there's so
much and so so I just got really
sensitive to it and I'm like man I just
can't do it so I have been eating I mean
impossible burgers do taste like they do
really taste quite like a burger yeah
beyond burgers are are I don't I don't
know if impossible is gluten-free or not
which is why I would not eat it yeah if
there's anything I'm sensitive to its
gluten yeah I can have a little bit of
dairy and not really notice as long as
it's like an accident
I'll grant like a little little bit of
like goat cheese that was our salad like
that's not going to make me
uncomfortable but gluten is something
that pretty easily makes me
uncomfortable so but be
Birger it's a little less like a burger
yeah it's still good yeah
the vegan discussion is a big one so
yeah I will say a couple things I have
done a vegetarian style diet in the past
and I feel so much better person when
I'm seeing me since the Thin Mint days
or before the birthday so yeah when I
was in like high school in college I
really was not into meat at all Wow um
but when I started doing Crossfit and
when I started exercising more I started
craving it and so I know my body feels
better yeah when I eat some meat I do
think that there are ways to source
ethically raised responsibly naturally
raised and fed meat from you know a
local source or from an online meat CSA
through regenerative agriculture in a
way that makes me feel good at least
about the meat that I'm buying and
eating not subscribing to like the
factory farming system but what I tell
people who are like oh I don't know I'm
reading these documentaries and I'm not
sure try it you've done a whole 30 whole
21 what clothes you've done already
you've been eating like you eat for a
while you know how you feel when you eat
like this if you want to see what it
feels like to do a vegan approach then
do it but do it by the book for 30 days
do it you know the right way really
stick to that like experiment buy and
eat real food so I'm not certain that I
would classify like the impossible
burger as real food to be arrests if you
look at the ingredient list however oh I
get it I know and then I have a vegan
reset outlined in food freedom forever
that hopefully will teach you how the
plant-based protein sources that you may
want to bring back into your life work
for you well you saw the ring work up
the whole three what's the downside of
the plant-based proteins versus hmm it
depends you know everything that we
eliminate on the whole 30 most Year
plant-based protein sources can be
problematic are commonly problematic to
varying degrees across the broad range
of people so like gluten for example is
really problematic for some people not
at all for others that's the whole point
of the whole thirty experiment but if
you are gonna eliminate plant-based
protein sources and during a whole
thirty then at least when you go to
bring them back in you'll know whether
seitan works better than soy or whether
quinoa works better than you know an
impossible burger so that's kind of the
benefit of doing like an elimination
style approach for your vegan plan yeah
I heard that
when your body absorbs the protein of
natural protein it absorbs a hundred
percent of it and maybe there's a
specific element of it but let's just
say of it and with plant proteins that
your body only takes like 70% of it well
I mean I think that there can be some
compounds in plant-based protein sources
that may make some of the nutrition less
bioavailable so like Steven Gundry talks
about lectins as one example again
highly variable different for everybody
the best way to know for yourself is
just to experiment you can read a book
or you can watch Lucky Penny months
right elections are the things and
they're in beans they're and they're
only basically like all plants all
plants yeah there are no plans to
varying degrees vegetables are you
saying
yeah Rockley yep like they are yeah not
necessarily problematic for everyone
he's got you know he's got like a whole
approach I'm so glad because that's the
whole reason and not have beans right
that was kind of the old school paleo
approach version to not enlighten me
yeah I got the rough like well and and I
think it again there might be something
to it but there are other compounds in
beans that may be problematic so peanuts
are you know potentially really
allergenic and they're one of the
proteins that have been actually shown
to like cross the gut barrier and
interact with the immune system so I
obviously is incredibly problematic from
an allergenic perspective and then maybe
the phytoestrogen perspective beans
contain FODMAPs which can promote
digestive distress which fermentable
carbohydrates of a gas and bloating that
a hog and they're sent with me yeah so
again it's like these things can be
problematic and how do you know if
they're problematic for you you are
emanate them you add them back in and
you compare your experience yeah you
know we're not we're definitely not I
think I just realized that kabocha
squash makes my stomach up bloated yeah
it's like it's one random one I'm like
yeah very sensitive I can't go and for
the same reason really yeah it's like
every time I have it I'm like why is my
psyche I feel bloated yeah you know the
same thing as beans right yeah that's it
okay so my girlfriend was having a
kombucha drink I'm like she's like do
you want something like no yeah I got it
on makes my stomach really bloated no
like it's really uncomfortable and I
said Kabuto
and kombucha are both no good for you
they're not on my list and this is why
you can't me
any blanket associations like Osgood or
ex food as bad it's like yeah highly
contexture I watched you TED talk on
someone the title was like the perfect
diet I'm like come on bring out I know
[ __ ] I knew that probably already
but and so I watched it and the point
was is that in you know when testing
insulin responses to specific diets that
were you know hitting the same macros
but different different different
ingredients so someone would have white
rice and have no reaction
the next person would have a huge
reaction same thing with like ice cream
whatever so the the point is is that and
this is the work that people don't want
to do but it's really about learning
your body it is and that's the that's
what you know I mean that my girlfriend
did whole three her and her husband did
it at the beginning of this year and
they did the entire process by the book
and including reintroduction and and
they you know they were able to then
recognize the triggers that created like
discomfort and what they could have back
in yeah bother them but it's really
about finger your own body out and
that's the work right yes it is I mean
if you really want to know you're gonna
have to do the work there's no magic
pill there's no magic formula no that's
gonna be completely you know for your
wellness in your own beta test it would
be really easy if someone could just say
like this is the one diet that's the
healthiest and it's gonna work that way
forever them but every single dietician
on the planet so I was like there is no
one-size-fits-all you have to figure out
what works for you and people are like
okay cool I buy into that yeah how do I
figure out what works for me and whole
thirty really is like the answer to that
how it is the structured self experiment
to help you get to that place so you do
have to do the work but I want to make
that work as easy as possible on you
yeah yeah it's amazing program so okay
well like you know what's your what's
your where do you see your freedom ten
years from now I don't know it's Jane
where is it right now we're what is
freedom to you right now yeah I feel
like my diet is like relatively
effortless I real
have to think about it in terms of like
those those were that decisions happen
in a split second I've got a really good
healthy balance I'm still playing around
with like four foods and performance
particularly in the gym and with hiking
but it's really really fun and I'm not
stressed out about it and that's it's
been like that for the last three or
four years so I imagine not changing
anytime soon which feels really good
yeah yeah and it frees me up to think
about other things yeah let me hit your
workouts real quick because I love
working oh yeah if there's two things
that I love to do I love to workout and
I love to cook yeah so so do you I mean
you do a lot of like I mean you're doing
pistols anywhere but you know deadlifts
and so do you follow a certain you've
I've also seen that you you'll do sort
of like you'll follow you'll use
someone's recommendations on like
progressions on learning things yeah so
I don't know is there do you have like a
gym freedom where you just kind of like
Evan flow through what feels right or
art or is there sort of like a general
routine for you know it's like the least
structured thing I don't write anything
down I don't make any plans like the
night before I usually I will go into
the gym and just kind of figure out what
I need in the moment I call it like year
of strong and bendy but it's been going
on for like three or four years because
I have such a history with CrossFit like
Mike Bergner taught me to snatch Marc
Roberto taught me to deadlift Jeff
Tucker taught me gymnastics like I have
I've had the privilege of training with
some really great coaches mmm
so I have a lot of information did you
get to the point where you could do ring
muscle ups easily no I never done my
dips were never solid enough and I was
like I value my shoulders anyway I never
did those but you know I like doing what
I want to do and what I need to do in
the gym so it's a mix of like yoga some
strength stuff some body weight stuff I
do a lot of kettlebells still I'm still
doing a lot of powerlifting I'm not
really a limpet lifting much and I hike
a ton yeah it's just kind of
free-flowing like what if you have yeah
well you've described um hiking as your
church yeah and actually I just had the
girls that just left and I just did a
little post and I said girl times my
church yeah it's like that how do you
like did when did you figure that out I
figured it out during my divorce when I
hadn't hiked in a while because I hadn't
anything I loved in a while cuz
everything was horrible and falling
apart and I got out into the mountains
my son was so little like a couple
months old maybe or not even a year and
my head that chatter just wouldn't stop
and like the voice in my head was so
mean during this time period and after
about an hour hiking it quieted and I
cried oh my gosh I cried so hard and the
views like I have a picture from that
day and that was the moment where I was
like okay I can use this to like Center
myself and ground myself and eventually
it turned into talking to God and
hearing God and so yeah the mountains
are absolutely my just by yourself I
almost always do it by myself
yeah I'll really like to hike by myself
I'll take people out like I will hike
with people I hike with Brandon pretty
often but like the long ones I just go
for me yeah I am I'm not great at
meditating as much as I'm willing to do
for my well-being and stretching and
pushing myself and creating disciplines
for some reason that's the one that I
haven't been able to really let sink in
but I do feel some sort of meditative
state while walking hiking oh yeah all
that like it that's something meditation
yeah you call it yeah
where I I mean I can literally go out
and I love walking my probably my
greatest simple joy in life greatest joy
period maybe is to take the dogs go to a
beautiful hike and prefer me I actually
really love to be enclosed yeah that
feels really nice as opposed to being
super duper open yeah and those openings
and clearings can be nice but I like to
be in ya woods and to see them just take
off cuz I also don't use leashes with
them to see them take off and be free
yeah and be dogs and like feel the
energy of the mountain of the trees of
the bushes of the leaves of the Sun
peeking through in the most beautiful
way I mean I just cry like it's easy to
cry like I don't know I don't even know
what I'm crying about him just it's
literally like brimming with the
gratitude yeah that's what it feels like
I mean I do it it makes me feel so small
yeah but it also makes me feel so
connected
it reminds me that like the world is a
beautiful place it reminds me that like
my problems are not really that big yeah
it does wonderful things for my son he's
six and we hiked a lot were outside a
lot and I've noticed just such a
profound impact on you know his
temperament and his mood and just
everything when he oh he's an outside
kid oh oh yeah big time yeah that's cool
so yeah him a lot a lot yeah yeah he
does a lot of hiking and he really lives
how long did you go with a six year old
he has hiked he's done some pretty
baller hikes yeah that's yeah yeah he'll
go five six miles with me kids are way
more impressive than we give them credit
it takes a long time and a lot of snacks
but I'm on his timeline which is also
kind of interesting right with the dogs
it's like you're not on your timeline if
they want to stay for a little while
yeah staying and right so it's an
interesting perspective yeah and I just
you know I think everybody needs to find
their church their version of it I mean
I I think that whatever gets them
connected with source with energy with
God whatever you feel like it is to you
and feel some like feel that feel the
field of peace feel feel gratitude feel
feel connect it like you said yeah Wow
well where's your next hike do you have
like big hikes planned are you like I
want a hike Mount Kilimanjaro I just
came back from a week in Montana which
was incredible I did some really nice
beautiful long hikes there which were
fantastic um you know after this week in
LA I'm gonna go home and just do some
local do a little local hike up to a
lake
what um what's your so what's your
balanced ratio like tell me just about
like what it what it is that makes you
capable of coming out here and come into
LA and doing your work and go into New
York and doing all the things that you
need to do and you know working with
working with people and writing books I
mean we all have to have our own balance
so and I don't believe in balance is
50-50 that's yeah that's not a reality
yeah it's really about what elements do
you need in your life and how often do
you need do those for you yeah I first
always talked about the fact that I have
a lot of privilege in this area so I'm a
half-time mom I have a full-time nanny I
work for myself I set my own hours I
essentially get paid to go to the gym
and eat healthy and so there's a lot of
privilege in this area that allows me
to do the things that I do right not
every like single mom is going to be
able to to pull this stuff off I have
really good boundaries I actually think
I credit most of my like ability to
balance or stay centered and do
self-care to my boundaries I'm really
good about saying no when I need to say
no when taking a day off social media
why don't you take a day off and telling
people that they can't stay at my house
and whatever I need to do to make sure
that like my cup is full yeah that's
good yeah I'll have a hard time saying
no I know they do it makes me sad they
do I'm like oh that an easy times sort
of standing your ground or speaking up
for yourself yeah maybe to my own
detriment in that like empathy is not a
skill that has come naturally to me I
think I'm very empathetic now but I've
had to like learn and practice and I
think a lack of empathy growing up and
maybe even into my 20 he's made it
really easy for me to say no I know you
need me today I know I need this time
for myself and it probably didn't serve
me then but now I'm doing it in a much
healthier and more empathetic way and
now I found a way that for that skill
set that maybe was like not good for me
to be good for me what are the things
other than hiking do you want to and the
benefit of that which he's caught on
really quick do you want to teach you
son yeah food so he eats like real whole
food well weren't he snacks of course
like as you oh my that's Michael over
his neck he's eating like seaweed snacks
you know he likes the paper ship see how
the papers like in chips he eats like
hot dog heats so many hot dogs like you
know so you don't need crust okay okay
yeah yeah those are great oh yeah he
loves those
I'm he'll eat those cold you know like
that really yeah they're little deli
meat salami so just throw them the
ziplock absolutely there you go yeah he
loves them he likes olives if you ask
him what he wants to eat for dinner on
any given night he'll either say like a
hamburger with some butter and jelly or
like sushi you know he's a cool little
kid but this is all he's had like he
didn't grow up with like pizza or
McDonald's or chicken nugget it's like
for better or for worse I've heard that
a lot of kids are like McDonald's I
don't eat that crap yeah he doesn't like
yes yeah I mean and look it's nothing
against McDonald it's like you've made a
fortune off of it but if Oliver died
yeah
because everyone will realize you know
the it starts in small areas and spreads
so it starts in big areas and spreads I
guess a lot of times and so eventually
that practice of low quality high sugar
high we processed preservative food
won't have a place in this world and
yeah so evolve our diet McDonald's might
be the healthiest place we ever saw in
twenty six years from now yeah right I
mean I'm not averse to the occasional
in-n-out burger though animal style I
mean yes although that Thousand Island
dressing situation they hang on I'm like
what what is this creamy stuff on there
that's so good I know yeah good thing is
that's the one that doesn't bother me is
me yeah but what else I mean you've
dealt with a lot of things in your life
so I mean food obviously is something
that's really important in developing a
good relationship with it but you know
you've also dealt with addiction and
you've dealt with trauma yeah and so are
there certain practices that you have
started with your son to help him to
navigate that better yeah we've been
teaching consent from a very very young
age
consent for kids where it's like I don't
force them to give me hugs or kisses I
don't force him to give grandma hugs or
kisses like it is instead of me saying
like give me a hug it's like do you want
to hug me today or would you rather
high-five or would you rather fist bump
like we're teaching consent from a very
young age that your body belongs to you
and unless it's an authority figure like
a doctor who needs to perform something
medically or unless it's like a safety
issue like I need to grab you to pull
you out of the street like your body
belongs to you and he's pretty like
solid in that now and we don't force it
so if he would rather high-five or fist
bump that's cool it makes sometimes that
makes grandma upset but we try to make
grandma understand that there's like a
bigger thing at play he likes to play
games sometimes where he'll say like do
you like my kisses and I'll say no and
then he'll smother me with us is but we
have a signal so that he knows that no
means no yeah like no always means no
and so we have like a code word that we
use when I mean no but I really mean yes
right so we're touching some of these
things at a young age because I never
you know
wasn't something I learned and then I'm
trying to teach him right now the idea
that like it doesn't matter what other
people think of your choices about your
clothes or your hair or your because he
likes to paint his fingernails and now
we're at the age where it's like I you
know if the other boys think your nails
look silly or girly you have to decide
whether you like your colorful nails and
if you do that's really what is
important and so that's been a big
lesson this past year I find that these
concepts are easy to digest for him I
think so because I we haven't yeah he's
six like Society hasn't yet imparted
upon them all of the like messed up
things like boys can't have colorful
nails or wear else'd costumes right like
he's so young that he doesn't understand
of course he has colorful nails like he
loves colored he loves Batman and Legos
and trucks and pink fingernail polish so
I think he does get it from an early age
because we are weren't trying to like
reverse what society has taught him
mm-hmm I almost have a harder time with
it because I'm the one who has to like
unlearn everything I was taught growing
up about boy things and girl things and
what other people think of you and all
that jazz like I'm struggling with it
more than he is he's not jaded he's not
he's not he's not I'm scarred he he
doesn't have traumas to deal with he
doesn't have all kinds of past past life
yeah situations to navigate well what's
um what's your idea of like the perfect
grocery store like if you were to walk
into a grocery store in the future what
would that look like and I would want to
see all the whole thirty approved things
all in one section of course I would
want like all perimeter I don't know how
you have a store that has so many
perimeters and not as much middles but
that would be genius if an architect
configured it goes in a circle it's like
a maze around if you swirling around and
you have to I'm surprised Vegas hasn't
come up with this because they want to
keep you in they don't want you to get
out Ricky is gonna escalators in walk
out and it's real confusing so yeah I
think that they could make parameter be
actual the whole entire store could be
perimeter I'd love to see labels super
clearly spelled out you know yeah it's
like you can't have any more of those
misleading like green checkmark heart
healthy but it's loaded with sugar kind
of things and I would love for people to
be able to test test run some of this
stuff I don't want to buy an $8
sauce if I don't know if I love it or I
don't know how to use this cut of meat
like can I have someone there doing
education if you could combine a grocery
store with some kind of like cooking
education ooh oh my gosh that'd be
incredible right thing right here on how
to cook like this is kohlrabi what do I
do with this and someone shows up and
they're like here's how I use kohlrabi
wouldn't that be magical when I wrote my
book called pretty intense yeah the name
of the show I did 50 recipes in it as
well and wrote them and photograph them
even and you have to include simple
things like how to make butternut squash
roasted butternut squash people don't
know I know I know
yeah I just don't know right right but
it's then then you teach them that and
then it's like okay well if I can cook
my butternut squash this way I could
probably cook my sweet potato and other
root vegetables this way and then it's
like bingo now you know how to cook
vegetables and you're done and it's so
easy but introducing people to that
concept I think is so magical I think
that may be your next stop then okay
cool you want to open it together
there's a whole threat to food freedom
yeah forever - what are we calling this
no the magical grocery store got a raise
you atm yeah yeah yeah well I'll I'll be
there
thank you I love it cool what have you
like a signing or something yeah sure
perfect good
[Music]
you
you